we have a lot to get to joining us now
the author of the deep state Fox News
contributor jason Chaffetz the author of
the Russian hoax Fox News legal analysts
greg jarrett author of the case against
the Democratic House impeaching Trump
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
congressman Chaffetz I'll begin with you
if this is the case all of these other
people that we know lied to Congress and
in the case of Hillary they were
subpoenaed she did delete them she did
acid-wash the hard drive and she did
bust up devices what where's her
pre-dawn raid where's the pre-dawn raid
of everybody else I mentioned remember
Bryan Pagliano was the IT specialist for
Hillary Clinton twice twice I issued a
duly issued subpoena he refused to show
up in Congress not only was there not a
pre-dawn raid they never arrested him
they never prosecuted that never did
anything about him instead what you had
was this FBI and the Department of
Justice handing out immunity agreements
so that they got the easiest treatment
possible at the same time as you point
out there were emails and documents
classified information so highly
classified even I as the chairman of the
Oversight Committee could not see this
information it was out in the wind it
was told up to up to 300 people had this
secure information in a non classified
setting and the Department of Justice
did nothing it's the duplicity it's the
it's the unbalance it's that Lady
Justice peeking under a blindfold and
acting differently for the Democrats
than you do on Republicans that's so
disgusting yeah at Gregg I want to get
your thoughts on this well Jason is
absolutely right and in fact Huma Abedin
and Cheryl Mills two of Hillary
Clinton's top aides clearly made false
and misleading statements to the FBI and
emails prove that those were false
statements and Jason during a committee
hearing Intelligence Committee hearing
confronted James Comey about it and
Comey said quote well there's always
conflicting recollection of facts you
know this from the same guy who used no
facts no evidence no probable cause to
launch a dilating and improper an
illegitimate investigation of
Donald Trump and now his longtime friend
and Ally Robert Muller is pretty much
doing the same these are processed
crimes but the indictment of Roger stone
only shows today that Muller has failed
to meet his mandate no one has been
charged with a crime for which Muller
was appointed you know professor Terzi
which you've talked about the
criminalizing of political differences
here every one of those people I
mentioned and Greg just mentioned are
guilty of the exact same thing that they
charge Roger stone with if we're going
to arrest one person if we're gonna say
that's justice
where's equal justice where's equal
application of our laws no I agree and I
think we shouldn't arrest any of them we
should let this be fought out in the
political arena look today's arrest is
part of a long pattern by Muller
he only arrests people for crimes that
occurred either after he came into
office crimes that were stimulated
essentially by the investigation well
crimes that occurred earlier but have
nothing to do with Russia
tax evasion bank fraud taxicab
medallions or one case where he indict
Russians who will never come into this a
country a show indictment of Russian
intelligence arresting somebody right
and the idea of arresting somebody like
Stone the way they arrested him is a
civil libertarian nightmare the ACLU
should be up in arms an hour later in
court the government conceded he was not
a flight risk he was not a danger they
accepted very low bail and they let him
leave they should have called his lawyer
and said please show up at the federal
courthouse tomorrow at ten o'clock he's
been indicted he'll be arraigned that's
the way white-collar criminals are
treated but what they want to do with
him with stone is to squeeze him the way
they squeezed Flynn and the way they're
squeezing Manta Ford and it's judge
Ellis who said they're not interested in
metaphor they're interested in what
metaphor can give them on Trump they
want to have him sing and the fear is
these people may also compose we know
some of them probably have already
composed
made up stories now stoner said he won't
do it of course Michael Cohen said he
wouldn't cooperate either so we have to
wait and see thank you all for being
with us